what gives a film a strong atmosphere
sometimes the elements that surround the
characters and story in a film the
cinematography sound design costume set
design come together to produce a
singular mood or feeling
[Music]
and when a film has a mood or feeling
that's consistent throughout a mood that
is unique from what we generally
experience in everyday life we often say
that film has atmosphere and one
interview director Robert Eggers
mentions just a few elements that create
the lighthouses atmosphere of a black
and white crusty dusty rusty musty world
in in a boxy aspect ratio with the pipe
smoke and the facial hair and the
Guernsey sweaters and the salt cod and
what's the story that then suits that
atmosphere pale death with treble dread
make the ocean caves our bed God who is
the surgeons rolled Dane to save our
supply and soul to four weeks for Eggers
the atmosphere is the foundation that
his stories grow out of and many of his
very specific controlled creative
decisions are in service of creating
that atmosphere a film's atmosphere as a
whole is complex and difficult to label
but we can seek to understand what it is
and how its created by looking at some
of the individual elements of the
lighthouse that helped create that
atmosphere this video is made possible
by Nord VPN go to Nord VPN comm slash
Thomas flight for 70% off a three-year
plan
[Music]
if we look at the script the creation of
the lighthouses atmosphere begins very
early on with a technical note shooting
the lighthouse in black-and-white wasn't
an option it was a core part of the
story and setting from the beginning
black-and-white cinematography serves to
emphasize textures in place of color the
lighthouse is a world of texture every
surface feels covered in grime dust or
mold it's all rusting rotting and
disintegrating the choice of black and
white is also the first step to set the
world in a place unique from our own it
looks and therefore feels different to
us black and white cinematography even
makes clear skies feel gray and
oppressive when looking at
behind-the-scenes footage for the
lighthouse it strikes me just how
strange seeing these characters and this
world in colour feels starkly
illustrating just how vital black and
white is to the feeling of the film just
below this is a second technical note
the aspect ratio of 1.19 two one is the
middle ground between a perfectly square
frame and the four by three silent film
ratio it was briefly used during the
transitional period from silent to sound
Eggers describes his choice as being
motivated not as an attempt to ground
the film in that history but to create a
frame that would be optimal for
composing images with the height of the
lighthouse itself and simultaneously
create an enclosed claustrophobic
feeling two elements that directly
relate to the atmosphere the film looks
like it's lit almost entirely naturally
but the slow black-and-white film stock
required extensive bright lighting the
scenes that look like they're lit by a
single flame are actually 500 watt bulbs
in the lamps it's almost as if these men
are lit by the piercing harsh light of a
lighthouse cutting through the darkness
there are more technical details in how
this film was shot that I could lay out
in this video like the choice to shoot
on lenses that are almost a century old
giving many shots the very specific
texture where the image is out of focus
and vignette includes
of the frame but the key to notice here
is that no aspect of the cinematography
was arbitrary each decision was made to
serve the atmosphere Eggers was trying
to create
[Music]
sound is a vital element of atmosphere
in fact when I think of atmosphere in
film I usually think first of david
lynch's Eraserhead
and the way sound design creates an
entire world surrounding the characters
in that film
[Music]
[Laughter]
the lay house similarly uses sound
design to remind us of the forces that
are constantly just outside the frame
surrounding our characters whether it's
the wind the waves the seagulls the rain
something more sinister and mysterious
or the foghorn
the foghorn that feels like it never
stops
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you get the feeling that the foghorn
alone could drive these men to madness
[Music]
might even drive the audience to madness
one of the impressive things about the
lay house is that Eggers and his crew
found a piece of rock on the coast of
Nova Scotia and built a working
lighthouse and the accompanying
buildings shooting on a real location
with real elements battling actual
weather makes those elements
ever-present in the film's production
and then in the film itself Eggers and
his teams close attention to period
detail when building these sets
designing costumes and writing dialogue
all work together to create a feeling of
a specific time and place and while
period accuracy in a film doesn't always
create atmosphere a world that has a
lived-in quality does that quality
extends the world of the film beyond its
running time creating an atmosphere that
feels like it exists outside of our
characters in the moment the story is
happening as if it haunts this place
long before they show up and after the
story ends but it's not just these
elements that create atmosphere but the
way they're presented if we return to
the script we can see how deliberately
elements of the atmosphere are
introduced a few at a time placing
emphasis on each part of the atmosphere
as it assembles we hear the foghorn
before we see anything and the first
thing we see is fog
the mechanical chugging of the ship
might as well be the engine in the
foghorn room
we see and hear waves all elements that
establish the atmosphere before we even
see the characters or the actual
lighthouse
[Music]
some people may object to this emphasis
on atmosphere saying that story should
come first but this atmosphere is
crucial to what the lighthouse is the
lake house has a story but it's
ambiguous asking more questions than it
alternately answers it deals with many
themes and can be interpreted in
different ways if you go to see the
lighthouse with four friends you'll
probably walk out of the theatre with
five different takes on what's happening
but you probably all felt the same
atmosphere and that atmosphere is the
uniting force that grounds the film even
as the characters and the story lose
their grip on reality this video is
sponsored by North PPN Nord VPN is my
personal choice in VPN a VPN is a great
tool for taking back control of your
privacy and security online increasingly
these days content on the Internet is
divided or excluded based on geographic
location with Nord VPN you can choose
from any of their thousands of superfast
servers in over 60 countries and it
makes it look like you're visiting a web
site from the location you choose it's a
great way to get access to content in
other countries when you need to or get
around firewalls that might be censoring
things giving you a way to take back a
little bit more control of your internet
use when you go to Noor VPN comm slash
Thomas flight you'll get 70% off a
three-year plan that means your monthly
cost will only be three dollars and 49
cents use code
Thomas flight at checkout or go to Nord
VPN comm slash Thomas flight to get 70%
off a three-year plan plus an entire
month for free
[Music]